SPEAKER 1: My grandparents
have low vision
and aren't as mobile.
I wanted to build something that
could help them move around,
and then I met--
--Sara.
SPEAKER 2: There's a
mailbox in front of you.
Move right to walk around it.
SPEAKER 1: We're in
separate continents.
So we had to find a way
to collaborate remotely.
I even learned a
little Portuguese.
Our app uses computer
vision and a combination
of neural networks powered
by Google Cloud's AI.
One network helps identify
the objects the camera sees.
SPEAKER 2: There's a coffee
table blocking your path
to the door in front.
SPEAKER 1: We hope
that eventually anyone
can use the app for indoor
and outdoor navigation,
and even on public transport.
SPEAKER 2: To take the red
line, turn left and then right.
SPEAKER 1: But it
doesn't take a computer
to see where that would take us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]